welcome I'm Adam Brody I'm here at
BuzzFeed I'm here to read you're thirsty
tweets I want Adam Brody to be in my bed
caressing my body and singing through
the trees in my ear and wearing eyeliner
I could do the first and the last and I
could do the second but it's not my
voice in that movie because I can't sing
I certainly can't sing about hi so this
sounds like this through the just about
my sexuality is when summer Roberts
can't find a napkin so she makes Seth
Cohen lick picante offer pinkie in
season 1 episode 6 of The OC genuinely
don't remember it was it was sexy I want
Adam Brody to mmm the living mmm out of
me until I'm begging for more and I
would actually eat at Danny's for that
man that's funny that's why I went
through my dream and his Adam Brody and
Jennifer's body including the murder and
demon stuff I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
that's respectable had a very scary
dream that a whale was trying to eat me
but then Adam Brody became my boyfriend
so it was all good did the whale you
still my crush on Adam Brody is still as
intense as it was when I was 15 please
kiss me so hard
it's very sweet thank you can I just
wick lick whipped cream off Seth Cohen
body question mark palpable please the
OSI is yours do what you will watching
in the land of women for like the
millionth time I want Adam Brody
like now as promised God Adam Brody I
just want to put your thighs in between
mine and ride you like a t-rex what Adam
bird guest star on my life as my hip
older brother who left at 16 due to
serious problems at home but it's still
always fun that's nice I thought it's
gonna be sexual and I'm writing my body
is ready
I think if Adam Brody were any more
perfect my eyes would have a meltdown
and I'd go blind that's very nice
um just wait okay Doug Leier is the
seasons past Adam Brody is the most most
perfect human ever I love him so much I
wish I could rub his nipples I'm like
cheese office but jeez my butt it I want
to hump lips with that Oh Brody I don't
know what lips were referring to
straight-up
can't watch porn why would anybody have
sex with these guys who's the Adam Brody
of porn I'd watch that guy have sex but
there's someone I'm sure there's someone
filling that void so to speak cleaning
up my house relaxing having
inappropriate thoughts about Adam Brody
at work out then Sex in the City - with
the room you later that's lovely it's a
lovely way to spend your your day it's
like perfectly healthy and look out then
Sex in the City - with my roomie you're
cleaning up the house you're relaxing
you're healthy to have sexual thoughts
sound like you got it together thanks
thanks for joining me I hope that was as
uncomfortable for you as it was for me
I'm flattered I am and
ready or not it's gonna be in theaters
August 21st and I promise you it's a
good time adios arrivederci a [ __ ]
[Music]